this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show where america hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life
and your money i'm john deloney joined
here by best-selling author
ramsey personality and all-around good
human being rachel cruz how are you
doing great jon yeah family's good yeah
we're good
just surviving you know for real sort of
thriving too it's sort of
yeah it's almost the week can you sort
of thrive it's almost the weekend thrive
sounds like uh yeah i don't know if you
can sort of drive thrive
it is what it is we're there we're there
very cool well we are taking your calls
on life
and money and relationships and all the
things
that we can help you with rachel's
really smart and i will help drive today
so give us a shout at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
carlos in tampa florida carlos what's
going on
hey how are you guys doing thank you for
taking my call you bet man thanks for
calling what's up
so um i came from south america i
remember my wife here in the united
states
we have a baby five months old now
and now we're trying to figure out what
to do next
when my plan was to get into a mortgage
and get a house
i came with no debt but my wife has an
80 000 in student loans and right now we
have
enough to pay it off i mean i'm talking
about like 95 000
and the student loans is 80 000 but i'm
trying to figure out what
if we should prioritize that instead of
thinking about getting into a mortgage
and i'm just getting trying to get that
advice from you guys
carlos you're a stud man how did you
guys accumulate 95
000. uh cyber security man i
t that made him my wife worked hard she
said
you said it like it was like a scam you
were like cyber security bro
we got it that's awesome man hey those
tech jobs they are
they're paying she's an elementary
school teacher as well so so that also
helps
that's awesome that's fantastic so great
well carlos number one congrats on the
baby
i know your life has just been turned
upside down in all the most wonderful
ways so congrats
so our rule of thumb here when we talk
about buying a home
is that we say we want you completely
out of debt
and a three to six months worth of an
emergency funds so your expenses that
total three to six months have that
saved in the bank
and then save up for a down payment from
10 to 10 to 20 for that down payment
so those are that's the tactical the the
what
now the why behind all of that is that
you'll realize soon after you are in a
home and own a home that a home
home ownership is extremely expensive
things happen
i mean just the other day our gutters
screwed up we had an ice storm in
nashville and all of our gutters filled
with eyes half of them fell off the
house i mean it's just
i need to get a new roof out of we got
it inspected high fived
and then two months later we gotta get
it well we went in the crawl space last
weekend before a date and uh an inch of
water in the car like i mean it's just
stuff just
happens when you own a home and it's
expensive and so
what ends up happening is a lot of
people rush into home ownership because
it's kind of the dream right like you
own a home and it's exciting and it's
fun
but you have no money you have debt and
you have no money and people
go in and end up that this house becomes
a burden
and a curse rather than the blessing
that it should be so
carlos if i woke up in your shoes
tomorrow i'd write a check for the
student loans
i get it i get it it's gonna hurt carlos
it's not fun but listen
but it is fun because at the other end
of it though you have no payments you
have
nothing and then if you want to bump the
rest of that 15 grand up depending on
your expenses
save that and then save a little bit on
the side you guys are killing it for a
down payment
then i would buy a home because i
promise if you go this route even though
it sounds just like this simple formula
you will move into that home and when
something comes up it's more like an
inconvenience than a complete crisis
right one question i had out yeah
one question i had on that is should we
be waiting or trying to wait for
a loan forgiveness now that they're
giving away some kind of forgiveness for
teachers
is that something i should be looking
forward to
well there's talk of student loan
forgiveness from dc but
pieces of it or yes but honestly here's
the thing about
the legislation all of that like it's
not like the president of the united
states
can just wave a wand and it happens like
there's a due process
it has to go through to actually let
that happen and we don't know if it will
when it will so in my mind carlos
i don't want to i don't want to depend
on washington dc
to change my life or waiting on them to
do things i i'm gonna control what i can
control and right now you can control a
lot like you yourself without dc
can do a lot for your family and not to
get too political but they promise stuff
i mean if you remember
10 12 years ago they said if you went to
school and took out loans they would
forgive those loans if you worked in a
certain sector now
so it's not happening carlos i had a
ringside seat
watching some of the most brilliant
minds combined with some of the most
extraordinary
young men and women who went to law
school and i was an administrator to law
school
and many of them chose to go into the
public sector
to help the least of these in our
communities because
of the public forgiveness program and
then it was year six year seven after
practicing
when suddenly they would apply to have
these loans forgiven
and they were either it just completely
ignored or rejected
right right and here's the other part
carlos and this is just me i'm a guy who
signed up for a bunch of loans i got a i
got we got too many degrees in our house
between me and my wife
we signed up for a bunch of loans we
didn't know what we were doing but we
we did we saw the numbers they just
weren't real and we something like oh
that's a
problem for a future don to handle i
have
a integrity i've got an ethical issue in
my soul
i told somebody i'm gonna pay you back
if you help me get through school
you guys carlos y'all are of means y'all
figured it out y'all have worked really
hard and you've got this money here for
me it's a matter of
you know we can we don't need to wait on
the government we're not going to wait
on the government they may or may not
who knows
and it's going to come with strings you
got to have um you know public service
all this other stuff
you guys have worked hard you told
somebody hey if you give us this money
we're going to pay you back
pay him back pay him back and then be
done with it wipe your hands of it
you'll have in a few months you'll save
up that emergency fund
and then it's off to the races i think
that's a great point too and
i mean just to applaud you carlos i mean
you guys are killed i mean he's from
what do you say costa rica
from yeah uh south america south america
yeah i mean came in
killed it i mean you're i mean you're
doing amazing carlos and you guys can do
this
you can do it the numbers are here and
you're only going to go up from here
that's the exciting part is
like you said you have to meet like it's
there because because you did what was
right you know what's right
like yeah so i hope that helps carlos
and um
probably more important than that call
is this um you mentioned
in that last call right before a date
y'all are hanging out in the crawl space
i have to i have to explore this with
you
we can go here it's not that interesting
no winston
my dates are different me and sheila's
dates are different we don't start in
the attic winston
has a crawl space that's like his man
room like down under the house like
where his tool bench is like the
the shock in the crawl space well they
say cross-sites you can stand up in it
so i guess it's time to stay in space
the stance space
the biggest traps down there no no it's
not a basement because it doesn't have
heating and air and all of that like
it's
anyways it's not that interesting
anyways he went down to check on a
mousetrap if you really want to know
cause there were mice down there and he
was going to get seattle's mouth
stripping
inch of water inch of water so we gotta
go get a lovely learning about my
friends marriages because you're so
different
our reservations are in 30 minutes he's
like i gotta go get a pump and i was
like
sounds like the beginning of a classic
rom-com to me this is a classic rom-com
hey we got a date hey everybody let's
head down to the crawl space
it's called i i don't know
money and relationship triple 825-5225
give us a shout and we will walk along
with you glad you're with us this is the
ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices and they make it
simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm john deloney
joined here by best-selling author and
good friend rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls on life
and money triple eight eight two five
five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the board's lit up and kelly's
waiting for your call
let's go to adam in syracuse new york
adam what's going on
oh no not much dr dean just come back
from work
calm because i was wondering how to get
my wife on board with everything that
dave says
you know i've been doing the program
since
late january and i got about
40 000 dollars in debt
not including her vehicle with her
vehicle it'd be about 55.
and i just want to change my family tree
and be able to purchase our first home
by next year
oh man well i appreciate your heart dude
and congratulations on turning this
first corner here
rachel you've heard this question for
years and years talking with couples
yeah so adam what's her biggest
hesitation what what causes her
not to want to get on board
um well she works full-time as a nurse
at the va
and she's also going to school
for her rn and i think she's really
focused on that
which i'm super proud of her for but i i
really don't know her hesitation she
when i first mentioned dave to her she
got out online
read some negative reviews
for all of us i'm like believe what you
want to believe i go this guy is making
absolute sense to me
and i'm with it it's just hard to do it
by yourself
yeah you're right it's almost impossible
to do it by yourself if two of you are
not
on the same page okay so what i so it
doesn't sound like
she is because i talked to some people
in the spouse is like oh i don't want to
budget because i just want to have fun
and not be accountable
or some people say i just want to
continue to do what i do because
i i deserve it you know i mean like
there's kind of some entitlement
issues that i hear a lot but i don't
hear that from her i just hear that
she's skeptical
of the process so
i mean she she's the saver and i'm the
spender
and yeah um i'm i limit myself on
everything now so
well i was going to ask i mean i just so
i wonder if it just
sounds like a really big thing to to to
bite off for her because she has all
these other things she's doing and she's
thinking oh this thing is going to
take over but what you both have to
understand is that yes when we say work
as a married couple you definitely work
together
but one of you naturally is probably
going to do more and be more excited
than the other like winston
he's the nerd in our relationship like
he's the one that honestly does the
excel
he we do every dollar for a monthly but
he has an excel thing to map out
the future he always wants to talk he
you know he'll want to talk about it i'm
the one that's like uh
i kind of want to watch the bachelor
like i don't like you know that doesn't
mean i'm not on board but i'm not as
excited as he is or he's the one that
pays all of our bills he
he does it all even though i know what's
being paid and we're on the same page so
so for her she just you just need her to
you guys come together and agree hey we
want to start this process but the heavy
lifting of the tactical day-to-day
can honestly come from you adam and that
that's okay from from our perspective
adam how did you bring it up to um
you know we were laying in bed one night
talking yeah that's your problem right
stop are you serious awesome okay so
it's great you're laying in bed
you roll over and you flutter your
eyelashes at her
and she flutters alice's back at you and
you say baby have i got a deal for you
is that how that went
yeah kind of come on man you got to be
more smooth than that how long have you
been married
eleven eleven years been together yeah
eleven years
oh adam man okay so a couple things that
you said that i want to make sure
are you a schemer have you always had
some things
do you always are you the guy who brings
good ideas she's a saver she's a nurse
she's
working in hospital like she's she's
predictable making it happen yeah are
you the guy with like hey
listen yeah
yeah i think i am so you
when you first called you talked about
her car payment
your debt and so what i would tell you
is you guys have a pronoun problem
and what i mean is if you have a you
and a her in a marriage and then the you
is
coming to the uh oh i'm sorry you're not
here y'all are just together okay
you all been together for 11 years yeah
we have two children together and
we've been together for 11 years ah okay
so
if you haven't committed right if y'all
are just riding this out together as
a in a committed relationship why aren't
y'all married can i ask yeah you can ask
um i i think she's afraid of commitment
is she afraid she's with you for a
decade brother sounds like she's afraid
of you
[Laughter]
that could be like a very well could be
adam you know the truth is is that
is that real is that real uh
honestly i don't know but you're
probably right on the money
so here's what i would suggest brother i
would suggest
sitting down with her and talking about
what's the future going to look like
when you have two kids when you're not
married when you've been together for a
decade
suddenly the days turn into weeks and
the weeks turn into months and suddenly
you've been together three years and
five years and we'll think about this
later and suddenly the future starts to
happen in front of you
and that's when one of you peels off to
go back to school to start trying to
create their own future because we're
clearly not on the same page i've got
mine you've got yours
i'm gonna go make some more money for me
so i can get a different car for me and
suddenly
you're gonna wake up and you're both
gonna be sitting on a couch and you're
gonna be two inches apart from each
other you're gonna be 2000 miles away
from one another
and coming in with something like this
program which is we've got to work
super close together not close together
we have to be one on this deal
because it's hard and it is back and
forth and
months on top of months and suddenly you
wake up and you're a united couple
and you're two or three years down the
road and you have this entire new
trajectory so when you talk about want
to change your family tree
right now you got two plants in the same
house so at first you got to do is you
got to
decide we're going to have one tree
we're going to do this one thing
together
and we're going to raise these kids in a
certain way we're going to build a
future together
and a part of building the future
together rachel is we're going to do
money together
right so your heart is right adam your
spirit is right your ideas are right but
they're just out of order right now
and the first thing you got to do is to
circle back to this extraordinary woman
you've
you've you've created a life with for
the last decade plus
and say hey let's make this a unified
thing moving forward right for sure and
the richness that comes from that so not
just
the commitment to say we're gonna get
married not just the commitment that
we're going to work together through
money not just the commitment that we're
going to do parenting together well like
that whole life that you're bringing
together it's almost like all these
separate puzzle pieces and you start to
bring it together and it is a beautiful
thing
while i feel like people it's dog
marriage it's stable
right yes there's something about it
that the richness of your life
it increases because there's a level of
vulnerability
and um unity that you've never
experienced before to say hey
we're going to be in this together and
it's it's something that i feel like
is it it it enhances your life
and it's something about there's
something about being tethered in
being anchored in not even knowing that
yeah yeah and i'm gonna fall off this
mountain sometimes
but i'm not gonna die right i may bang
up the side of it but i'm anchored into
something
yeah and somebody may shove me off she
may shove me off
but we are anchored in here right and so
yeah it's circling back to we got to be
on the same page
working to gather
how hard is it so you guys how long you
all been married 11
11 years okay there's a myth that
all of a sudden you wake up when then
you figured it out and there's no more
discussions no more eye rolls no more
whatever when it comes to budgets
right that's not true right no
no i mean i think the logistical side of
the budget goes pretty quick
like the budget meeting quote-unquote
like we'll talk when we do it and it
sounds like oh of course she does but we
really really do
yeah before the month begins we sit down
we're like hey let's look at march okay
well we're going
to the beach this week on spring break
we're going to do this and this and you
start kind of mapping out and we
and so all of that takes eight to ten
minutes like we do that fast
but it's the other parts of knowing
being known by each other
in a deep way because money is it's it
reveals
a lot of who you are and so working that
closely with your spouse
yeah can create some moments where like
oh i mean i'll be honest like i
love amazon right now i know people hate
amazon but i'm like i can't stop
and and like and it's under his like he
created the account years ago whenever
we got prime and so we obviously just
share the account but i know every time
i buy something
it's he gets a notification i'm always
like even though it's in the budget and
i know it
i'm the spender and he's the saver so
even those things and i'm like hey just
heads up
i'm getting um a new pan because our
non-stick
you know we really needed the house and
we need it
but it creates it just creates the
conversation that's right which is what
i love so
so for those of you out there who are
three years in five years in
it does get easier it gets more routine
but it always brings you back to a
conversation that's right
right that's right we had one at tractor
supply this weekend me and my wife oh
we'll hear about that we won't
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight two
five five two two five i'm john doloni
joined here by
rachel cruz and it looks like on the
debt-free stage
we've got a beautiful couple we've got
jared and stephanie from las cruces new
mexico
and i think i know what this means how
are you two good folks we're doing great
how are you guys doing today
outstanding outstanding all right so
tell us about las cruces
las cruces is a wonderful community that
is
about uh 1400 miles away we drove all
the way here
you drove all the way here how long does
that take you uh it's 20 hours
we broke it up in a couple days though
it was his birthday on monday so this is
his present
for your debt-free scream to be your
present i love it very cool
and so you're here to do your debt-free
screen how much have you paid off
we paid off 140 466 dollars
140 466 dollars and how long did it take
you
15 months whoa did you sell a house
no no you just crushed it okay so
how much what was your income what was
your rate of income during this time so
we started at
188 403 and uh we
increased it to about 206 512. 200 6512.
are you are you the nerd i am linda i'm
hearing all these very specific
dollars i was like man i'd be rounding
up
good for you good for you so 188 to 206
that's still a lot of money to pay off
in a year that means you are making an
extraordinary
income and you're still doing rice and
beans right yeah that's right i mean
we we both work in healthcare and uh i
mean
this last year there's all kinds of work
to be done anyway so we just
we're able to pick up shifts and work
extra wherever that may be
i mean stephanie is a nurse in the icu
so i mean
she picked up an extra 12-hour shift for
about 20 weeks i'd say
wow thank you thank you for your work
though i appreciate that so
take us back 15 months what in the world
happened so i'll take it back a couple
years ago i mean about three years ago i
was i'm a pharmacist and i
was doing a pharmacy rotation through
the rural area parts of new mexico and
uh
one part of that was i got to stay with
my uncle during one of those rotations
and uh
he was well into uh dave ramsey stuff
and he
uh kind of he knew that i had a large
chunk of change to pay off without
the salame loan and he's like you know
have you ever really thought about what
you're gonna do at that point and
i i really kind of brushed him by for
that moment my uncle john and uh
yeah you know i did i picked up his i
picked up dave ramsey's book the total
money makeover and
uh about maybe six months after that and
i was i was absolutely
hooked right away man that book was fire
man it was just incredible
and uh so about of course um
of course about two years ago my my wife
and i at that time were
not quite married yet but i had
mentioned her kind of the stuff that
i've been reading into and
i was kind of not wholly going into
paying off the debt because i mean i i
was still learning what that was about
and uh
she she initially was not on page but
um we got married and we both put our
bank accounts together and just were
we're on fire from there you know so
this sounds like the start of a joke
a pharmacist sits down to explain
something to a nurse right
how did that conversation go where you
rolled your eyes and you were like no
um there was a little bit of eye rolling
but we had a few road trips to
albuquerque where we listened to the
dave ramsey show together and then i was
kind of hooked after that
um because i got to hear it for myself
but right
a couple days after i got married jaren
took me to my bank and used all of our
wedding gift money
and we paid off my credit card so that
was kind of my introduction to what our
marriage was going to be like
all that money that we got from the
wedding was just sent away and she just
was like
i can't believe it so
how does it feel now because you guys
started marriage
this whole new way of looking at my i
mean you did it all at the same time so
now you're on this side of it you've
been married a little over a year
you're debt-free it was just crazy it
was a crazy time um
we were dealing with the pandemic like
everyone else trying to figure that out
working working as a nurse through that
was difficult
um and then we were trying to figure out
budgeting for the first time figuring
out marriage for the first time so it
was a lot of firsts for us and it was
difficult but
um we definitely praise god for all the
support that he's given us
and this was all him that's all we
that's what we wanted to say
that's why she was working 12-hour
shifts it's like
i'm good i'll be out i'm going to go do
this so
what kind of debt was this this was
obviously pharmacy school is really
expensive so
student loans what else my student loan
because i had gotten out of nursing
school
a while before that but i was just
paying the minimum payments i thought i
would never be out of debt that was my
mindset
until jaren kind of showed me that we
could do something different so
and then a little credit card yeah just
between yeah we'll see
the wedding yeah just took over yeah
that's awesome that's awesome
so what i mean you guys what the
beautiful thing about your story is that
you're starting all of this together
where we talked to some couples we just
took a call last segment right and
you're they're together but they're not
working together and they've already
created these kind of money habits in
their own lane so you guys started from
the beginning
so what encouragement do you have for
couples that are dating maybe they're
engaged
to get on the same page like how
important is it do you think to be
one in the subject when you get married
absolutely i mean you i could not have
done this without stephanie you know
this
i mean this this was all kind of
something that i had brought to her
attention but if it been just me
and not her i mean there's always that
wedge that's always going to be there
and
um and that that that is something that
we didn't want for our marriage we
wanted to go into our marriage knowing
that
um that we we don't have to worry about
the money issue as an issue
if we kept our bank account separate it
would have been a little bit more you
know there's more of a chance of it to
cause an issue or trouble i mean i mean
you always you guys know the rates of
divorce i mean
yep that's not something that we wanted
to be in our marriage and we know
um we knew what um what
what yeah no no no it's right no you're
exactly right and and two
last question with marriage because i
think we we did a thing money and
marriage so this is always fascinating i
love here talking to married couples
about it because
would you say your your marriage is
stronger
now than it would have been yes i i
think that
the the most important thing a part of
this is i mean there's
a whole grind that goes about being able
to pay off this debt
and um and i i've absolutely lean on
stephanie and a lot of the things that
we were able to do but
god oh my gosh like there's times that
you know you're just
watching your your paycheck go straight
towards the government
and it's i mean we're we're living on
much we're
living on much less than what even
stephanie made and
it it's hard it's incredibly hard it's
just it's just
sometimes like why why can't we you know
go out to eat like we used to that's
something we really enjoy
and um but i mean when you give it to
god
when you just absolutely just let him
help you handle your finances because we
are his managers it's his money
um it it does get you over that hill and
it's just that extra
boost and that extra stone to lean on
because he's just always there for you
and i just want to add of course it just
runs over into every other aspect of
your life
so i started um kind of budgeting with
food because i
you know overeating is an easy thing to
do um and i was able to lose 20 pounds
during this wow and then of course we
started budging our time with god more
like
we need to make sure that we're always
spending time with god every day and so
that's something that we do now too and
we have
grown closer to god to each other um
becomes stronger people
spiritually yeah it's amazing this
finance has nothing to do with it but
we've also grown spiritually because of
our right decisions in one area
it does it trickles through that's
awesome well i'm ready
so we i can't wait i can't wait for
y'all so
paid off 140 466 dollars
in 15 months making between 188 thousand
to 206
000 a better marriage better health
better spiritual life
man they did it jared and stephanie when
you're ready
count it down let's hear it three two
one oh glory to god
[Applause]
oh amazing amazing
i mean incredible can you imagine
driving up to
get your you know driving up to get your
uh
medication and your pharmacist drives up
in an 85 camry
and you think what are you doing and he
says i'm changing everything man
how cool is that doing it all and that's
what i love too because you sometimes
hear about these high-paying jobs and
these high
you know these high earners and they're
just living that they're living to the
very top of what they make
living in fantasy okay and and they said
you know what we're gonna scale down
for one year for a year for 15 months i
mean it's pretty amazing 15 months and
everything is different
what a great couple yeah no more 12-hour
shifts this is gonna be fun fun fun for
them
thank you for joining us this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm john delonie
joined here with rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls on money
and life triple eight eight two five
five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to mark in washington dc
mark what's going on hey guys thanks for
taking my call
i'm still fortunate to be able to talk
to you and actually feel fortunate about
the situation i'm in but
uh first time in my life having a little
bit of extra money is causing me
some stress as well so it's not all uh
roses there you go
hey this is this is a good call to take
so what's up man
it's a good call uh here's the picture
i'm 44
um hoping to retire at 60. i'm a wife a
wife and two kids eight and ten
about a hundred thousand in the bank um
seven hundred thousand in retirement
401k step ira hsa brokerage that kind of
thing
i have a pretty good income um over the
past couple of years it's pretty much
uh tripled wow about 350 to 450 yeah
yeah just uh change
jobs still in the same profession but
what do you do man it's a better
compensation
i'm a surgeon okay so you don't mess
around yeah
uh you know i was hoping to get on the
radio soon because i have a case at four
o'clock but
i have a small case i'm gonna be on time
so it's okay you're actually you're
replacing a knee as we talk man
you're you're a talented guy so what's
up
um so anyway um yeah so um
the only debt i have med school and i've
been reluctant to pay it down it's at
1.75
started at about 200 000 i got 120 left
okay
mortgage house is about 1.1 and uh down
to 550 on that
refinance recently about 2.25 percent
that's my only debt no credit cards no
cars
like that okay so you know recently i
came across
a bonus for work um for 2020 as the last
um
couple mentioned you know 20 terrible
in general but for health care workers
it did give us an opportunity to earn a
little bit more
sure so i i came across a work bonus um
about 169 000 and
where i'm struggling and i'm not trying
to say i'm in a terrible situation but
i have bouncing around in my head you
know how much do i keep in the bank
i've never started a 529 how much should
i put in a 529
do i do a 457b dump it all into a
brokerage account do i look at long-term
care so
i'm in that position and i just sort of
can't figure out what what to do
you got it man well thank you so much
number one
in a you keep you keep using very
passive language you just like
we're walking on the street and stumbled
into a bonus my guess is you worked your
butt off in some really scary situations
in a you were there when people were
hurting
and you earned that bonus and i'm
grateful for all the work you
have done and i'm grateful for your wife
holding things together while you've
been
um working like bananas this year so
yeah you earned the bonus
for sure um i have worked behind closed
doors with doctors
with their coaching folks through mental
health challenges through relationship
challenges and whatnot
and i'll tell you something that's
always been a mystery to me
is the love affair between a doctor a
medical practitioner
and their student loans you guys
love them you love to hang on to them
and pet them
and sing to them as though y'all are in
love and
here's what i think it is i've got i've
got one person that i i
work with now whose kids are in college
still has his student loans right loves
them deep in his heart right and
i we i give him a hard time about it but
it comes down i think
to looking at this as a math problem
instead of a psychology problem
and so i if i'm you and rachel hop in
here yeah sure
i would take that 165 000 and i would
pay off my
med school before the day is over today
i'd pay it off i would be free from all
of that and then i would start
considering going down the rabbit hole
getting my house paid off and then
moving forward
kids called yeah i was going to ask mark
what what causes you do you relate to
what john just said like what causes you
to keep the 120 around
yeah yeah so i mean it's just the
leverage of the 1.75 percent i i i have
this challenge
you know in my life to uh meet somebody
that has a lower interest rate on their
student debt
yeah and i haven't come across that
person yet you know i'm out of med
school about 20 years
30-year loans but i just feel like i can
beat that rate it doesn't weigh on me
um you know having that having that
burden it really doesn't
my wife's totally fine with it i just
feel like i can beat that beat that rate
yes so i think that's like you're saying
you're hitting on the math stuff and you
don't feel like it's weighing on you and
all that and you're in a great position
so honestly you're not losing sleep
at night over this thing you're not
mathematically because it's a small
percentage of everything you have but i
would tell you mark if you paid it off
today
and you woke up tomorrow i guarantee you
there is a level
within you spiritually emotionally all
of it that just is gonna
exhale just so just a little bit you may
not even realize it because you've been
hanging on to it for so long so
what we teach is getting completely out
of debts
first and foremost and so that would
mean yes just going and paying it off
just getting it out of the way
you have cash in the bank you earlier in
the call i wrote it down you have a
hundred grand what was the hundred grand
at the very beginning the call
is that cash that you have i know you
have seven hundred and we're talking
about
yeah your hundred dollars just sitting
in a you know savings rate yes that's
great okay
so i want you guys to get and see how
much is six months worth of living of
expenses for you guys you're in dc so
it's probably going to be a little bit
higher
dollar amount than someone living in
iowa figure it out what your lifestyle
is and keep that so maybe it's that
maybe it's a less a little more i don't
know so
put that aside keep that just boring in
a boring money market account boring
savings account because that's going to
be your liquid emergency fund if
something happens
then i would start to look at your kids
college and their ages again are what
10 and 8 10 so i would set up yep
yes so you may not even qualify because
of your income
for an esa so you may want to look at a
529 plan
and start putting some money away for
their college i think would be the next
best step to look at and then at the
same time
be funding retirement and throw an extra
at that house and because you you have
your house halfway paid off which is
amazing so i mean
you haven't yeah like we said an
incredible situation market i think you
can make a lot of ground financially
if you just stay focused you know you're
doing a couple of things here and there
it's kind of all over but if you just
make these steps and you guys do them
you're going to find progress
financially
so much faster i think than you have
mark what kind of surgeon are you
i'm a cancer surgeon cancer surgeon wow
and so is it
are you at on the front end
or are you more in stage four acute care
um well you know actually both um as a
cancer as a surgical oncologist
um probably about sixty percent of the
surgeries we do uh
the final diagnosis is actually not
cancer right so you know there's people
that get referred to us so i'm on the
front end but i'm also
you know an everyday sort of sort of
surgeon um
working in the office working in the or
so is there a up
early on especially march of 2020 march
april may
um the the folks in in in my in my
sphere
just my buddies and folks that i i am
connected to
man they they puckered up the elective
surgeries
overnight right and there were some
folks that were really scratching their
heads about man if we don't open up some
of these low-level things the whole
hospital system rolls over because so
much of our income is based on
come on in were you and was that your
case too
so it's really interesting right so we
shut down for six weeks in april and may
the health system i work for health
system
um they announced they were losing
publicly announced they were losing
about a hundred million a month due to
the elective surgery crisis so
there were you know there were places
crumbling sure and we were concerned
about
um obviously the health system the
patients we take care of our own
livelihoods
um but i don't know if you're seeing
this in your sphere but what i have seen
is
now that now that people are home people
want their elective surgeries because
they don't fit this work
so i did more surgeries in 2020 even
with shutting down for six weeks than i
ever had done
any other year in my career and that
trend is continuing
yes very cool so here here was where i
was where i was aiming
and it rebounded really well for you
which is excellent
the folks that i talked to on the front
end of this deal really got scared
because they thought that that election
that elective surgery
world was over and here's what i'm
getting at if you
even if you have this low interest rate
and yes man you can sit there and
give me a spreadsheet and make the math
work and as a surgical oncologist
that's what you do in your head probably
nobody knows risk like you do nobody can
sit down and say here's probability
here is i'm gonna be the the i'm gonna
walk into this room and i'm gonna make
sure somebody stays alive to tomorrow
that's an extraordinary uh power for
lack of better terms
but i want you to go back to if you've
got no payments you've got no debt
you've got no stress if elective surgery
is
shut off then you can be all about how
do i help other people not how do i
keep from falling apart thank you so
much mark for your service and for your
care man we love you
this has been the ramsay show thanks for
joining us and we'll be back
soon right here
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is
the ramsey show where america hangs out
to have a conversation
about your money and your life
i am john deloney joined here by
best-selling author and good human being
rachel cruz and we are taking your calls
on life and on money triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight
eight two five five two two five rachel
how are your little ones doing
they're doing great just man
five three and one five three and one
yes
and i've got almost 11 and five
you space them out well i feel like i
have a thousand people in my home and
you have
a million and a half oh it's there's a
human everywhere
a human everywhere and one's crying
always but it's great you know
it's great it is funny though like
there's some days i'm sure every parent
feels like this we were like
man that was like a good like that was a
good day and then some days you think
what did we do
what are we doing what are we doing the
random thing that my wife will say
she'll walk through house and she'll
just
quietly toss away remember when we used
to think we were busy
i know remember we used to think we were
tired remember that and she'll just keep
walking through the next room it's so
great
i laugh all the time though because i
think i remember so specifically it's
like so in my head
i we had this this lady in college she
like mentored a group of us and where
we'd go to her house and we'd talk and
we just like oh my god i'm so stressed
elizabeth
i have like three exams this week like
i'm like yeah i have
she had four kids i looked back and i'm
like her husband worked a lot like i'm
like i just want to call her
oh she probably thought you have no idea
no idea you have no idea
when i told my dad i called him and said
hey listen you're gonna be a granddad
there was no fireworks there was no ah
my son
his response first response was well
you're never gonna sleep again
and i remember thinking like that was
kind of deflating me that was the most
prophetic thing i think my dad ever told
me man
well you have good kids though you all
came over a few weekends ago and had
dinner with us yeah
hank i mean yeah yes they're both
wonderful but hank is just
the sweet i mean talking to charles by
our 16 month old boy
oh he was like can i feed him when
someone's taken out to bed he's like do
you need help winston
like oh yeah so listen in the car right
before we came in your house we said
listen
so sweet to our two kids don't screw
this up for us
for every kind thing you do we're gonna
we're gonna give you froot loops and
whatever
sugar money yeah we're gonna pay you
kids
and my son was like dad let's just do it
because it's right and my daughter was
like sweet how much
that's awesome all right let's go to the
phones let's go to erica in houston
what's up erica
hi dr john and rachel i'm so grateful to
be talking to y'all and we're grateful
that you called what's up
well i have a what i would consider a
good problem my business has been
extremely busy lately i own a couple
therapy private practice
i can imagine so
exactly and um so i know
it's time for me to expand into adding
some more therapists to come work for me
that i would train under me and right
now i have two interns
um but i am still seeing about eighty
percent of the the revenue comes from
the services that i
offer um so i've been having some
trouble finding somebody to hire
and now i've kind of uh i'll call myself
out i've had some really bad boundaries
i just started taking on
more and more clients uh myself and i
find myself with low
energy to be able to really do much else
other than to see
my clients and write my notes and
supervise my interns and that's about it
and so
why do you why do you feel like you have
to expand your business
sounds like you love counseling other
people
i do um i also love supervising
and i have another business i would like
to start that would be
uh separate and so i would like some
energy and time to be able to give to
that
and not so much into the clinical work
although i still like to maintain
clinical work
gotcha well i was going to point to you
john cause you're you are in this world
i mean
yeah what i find with therapists is they
you get to a point where it's exhausting
right erica you see clients eight hours
a day and it's at weird hours
and it's one of those things where if
you stop and just like hey i'm gonna go
home tonight and have dinner and watch a
tv show
there's that part in your brain that
says well that was 100 bucks right you
can always be working
always moving and then you the next
conversation is what's passive income
look like are we going to write a book
and then you realize there's not a lot
of money in books and i want to create a
curriculum and i want to start work so
you just start explaining so why do you
want to expand things do you want more
money
do you want more um you want more reach
to help more people what's your goal
here
i think it's it's two of those things i
do want more reach to help more people
and be able to offer a variety of
services so that we can treat more
people across the community and then
my other business is also focused on
mental health so minimalism and mental
health and
i'm going to need some time and energy
to be able to put into creating that
content to be able to put that out into
the world
which would also help more people gotcha
are you able to
let other people do their job
under your umbrella differently than you
do it but still effectively
yes i've been working on that because i
did hire a virtual assistant um
not too long ago and so i think that's
given me
some muscles in that although that is
difficult for me
and i would say to erica you can
probably speak into this john because
you're specific my brother-in-law he's a
therapist
and he's has a wait list all of that i
mean like it's it's insane
but people come to see him not a
practice necessarily right they want him
so how much of your clientele erica
would be okay
to go see someone else like the
percentage in that because i know that
therapy it's such a personal thing right
you you that people want to see you
i know that's why you're so good um what
would it look like to bring on say those
two interns but you make them full time
do you think you'll still have the same
amount of business do people will your
clients feel comfortable
going to someone else um we've
seen some trends in that so there's
still
obviously more people calling for me
once they learn that they're
that the other people are trained under
me most clients are pretty open to that
that's right that transfer of trust
there yep perfect
so here's what i'd recommend erica i i
would recommend
i just have experienced this with my
buddies who are therapists they get so
excited and then they go to a training
and it always comes at a time when
they're exhausted from their day
practice
right they're just hearing the same
married couple fights over and over and
they know what they're doing and they're
good at it
in fact they're excellent at it they're
getting the same calls and they go to a
training and they experience something
new
and they're like i want to do this with
this group of people and i could crank
out this business and i could hire these
people
and then you get a napkin somewhere in a
restaurant and you map it out you
realize
oh we can make this much money and help
this many people
and then you start as as our friend ken
coleman says you
you jump off the dock before the boats
all the way up right and so i'm going to
do two things one
we're going to give you a copy of our
friend christy wright's business
boutique which is going to give you some
actual it's going to help you walk
through the steps of starting a new
business
right you know how to run a business
you're running a successful one but
right now the business
is you and so how do you step away from
this business and then come up with
how do i hire how do i train how do i do
payroll how do i do hr how do i do
training how to do marketing all these
things
while also keeping the practice going
and the second thing is
i want you to take some time to i don't
sound so cheesy i want you to take some
time to dream and
actually paint a picture of what this is
gonna look like yeah right what would a
a friday afternoon look like for you if
your full
your real business is running your
supervision business is running
you've got a group of counselors trained
underneath you and then you're gonna
have to reverse engineer that back and
what do you have to start doing right
now to begin to build that practice
and then you're gonna have to work on
those boundaries and you probably have
to see one of your buddies to help you
with that one erica because that one's a
challenge for all of us who love helping
other people
but i appreciate your question and
houston needs more therapists i'm glad
you're there
don't give up on it hang on the line and
kelly will get you
that book stay tuned this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same problem financial lives christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget friendly option
and the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five taking your calls on money
and life here on the ramsey show let's
go out to charlottesville
virginia and talk to logan what's up
logan how are you doing
hey john hey rachel how you guys doing
good good good what's up
um so a little debate here between my
fiance and i oh you're going to drag us
into it huh
don't be the typewriter so we're getting
married uh on may 30th so coming up
pretty soon
um and we recently started fpu
um we're feeling pretty good about it
pretty gazelle intense between the two
of us right now we're working
seven jobs in in two weeks went from 11
grand in debt to
2 800. so way to go man working pretty
hard with that
yeah thank you um so
and i know this is a little farther down
the line but one of our goals um
is to purchase a house with cash um
within the next 10 years or so
um however i was thinking about it and i
think
so what she wants to do is just save up
after we get done with baby step three
go into
uh 3b and save up specifically for
the house however i think because of how
young we are i think it would be more
beneficial
to use that time to open up a roth i.r.a
i'm going to
max that out at 6 000 every year and
then what's left
over after investing into that um
put into either a money market or a
mutual fund to save for a large down
payment on the house
because we're right now i'm i'm 19 and
she's 20.
so the yield on that would be a lot
bigger if we start earlier
sure so the debate is save up and pay
cash right away for the house or not
right away it'll take years to save
obviously
or go ahead and take out a mortgage and
continue on is that that's the debate
right
save up and pay cash well no either
either way we wouldn't be we'd be
purchasing the house at the same time it
would just be
do we want to spend these nine
ten years before we buy just
saving for the house or should we invest
into retirement
and then what's left over after
investing every year put that into a
savings for a large down payment on the
house
but you're saying down payment when you
put it down payment you're taking out a
mortgage though so it's not cash
right right right i'm sorry not not not
i thought you were saying
by now but no would be the same time but
yes yes okay
let me let me make sure i'm
understanding this i'm sorry i
so do you take let's say there's a
hundred thousand dollars do you take 50
of that and start investing it now
do you have a hundred thousand dollars
though logan like i'm not making that up
yes but i'm saying but once you get once
you guys pay off your debt
you're gonna save up for that emergency
fund three to six months worth of
expenses
then what we would suggest that you do
if you want to buy a home
then is to save up babysit 3b for a 10
to 20
down payment and then start investing i
would not use baby step
3b to save cash and not invest
in a roth ira so i'm more on your side
on it
i would i would go ahead and keep
putting money away now if you want to
use
it would be baby step three right baby
step four is investing
and if you wanted to say hey we wanna
rent for six years and we're gonna save
up and write a check for a house in six
years
while we invest you can totally do that
i think that that's a great idea but i
would not miss
out on the investing to save up to pay
cash for a house
does that answer your question okay yes
yeah
i i wouldn't because because like you
said you guys are you guys are young
you have the time a mortgage is the one
type of debt we won't yell at you for so
if you did decide hey we are going to
just do a down payment of 20
go ahead and do the 15-year fixed rate
do the formula to buy a house the right
way
that's great you can do that but if you
guys were kind of
more on the quote-unquote weird side
which we like weird people and say hey
you know we're going to rent a small
apartment
we're going to live on nothing and we
for for eight years we can save up x
amount and pay cash for a house but
we're going to do that
that's awesome and you've never had a
mortgage in your entire life that would
be that would be great
so either either one of those is totally
is as great
from our book yeah does that answer your
question i'm sorry i know that was a
long way around
but okay no that's fine uh it does yeah
thank you and logan
um not to oversimplify this but you're
19 she's 20.
y'all feel like you're 100 years old
right now and then when you
turn 30 you're going to feel like man
we're really young right now right
and so it feels like you if you mess
this decision up
it's man you might as well you're not
going to start over your marriage is
going to be off to a sideways start
you all are so far ahead of the average
couple getting ready to get married
yes you just need to stop and pause for
a second y'all are crushing you're gonna
get married in a few months you're gonna
be off to the races
and go slow do it together right then
and rachel's right
when you when you're 30 you're gonna
love that you have a retirement account
that you started when you were 20 21
years old
you're also going to love you got a big
chunk of a down payment or
you all went ahead and rented for a few
more years and just started your whole
new family tree with no mortgage at all
that's right that's going to be awesome
all right let's go to gary in arlington
gary what is up
hey what's going on doctor d rachel how
you guys doing good good good
what's going on in your world man yeah
so
uh i'm in pharmaceutical sales i'm 27
years old i've paid off about 40k
already in student loan down
nice way to go brother i'm pretty much
debt-free
but i got this car situation that i'm
kind of hung up on i have no idea what
to really do
so my parents guided me into this
release of a rav4
um after i graduated
oh no gary dubalisia i think we just
lost you gary oh there you are you back
oh yep i'm here guys okay all right so
your parents
talked you into elise the rav4 yep rav4
um paid off all the lease payments so
now it's like do i save up this money i
got about 15k
left i got about 4k in savings uh
i'm starting to build up my uh emergency
funds but i'm just wondering like should
i like
build up and start saving to buy this
car should i maybe take out a loan pay
it off
sell it take that equity that i have
left and then maybe try to roll that
into a car that's a little bit more
affordable
since i am going to burn this car into
the ground with how many miles i drive
so
i'm just wondering like what i should do
with this car i feel like it's going to
be a sunken cost if i don't like
just keep on trying to like maybe save
up for it like buy it so
i was just wondering what you guys
thought yeah and you the 15k
is what was that you said at 15k and
what
uh so the 15k is to buy the car to buy
the car okay i hear you
i hear you yep yep so the lease payments
are done so i'm just like
what do i do with this like i feel like
i almost have a part of this car but
it's like i would just kind of hate
myself if i just like gave it
up i would have to pay the mileage
overage that i'm currently accumulating
with this job
how much is that how much is the mileage
over
so i just passed it not too long ago
with that so
the cap was at 36 i'm at like 38 right
now it's
i think it's like 25 cents a mile for
21.
for 2021 you've already passed the cap
oh no this is a 2018 rav4 no no but i'm
asking you
are you talking about for the year
you've already passed your cap
or for the the amount of the labor for
the the arc of the lease
so over the three years i was given 12k
mileage per year um and i've already
passed that
like i'm past the 36k that that's been
allotted for the lease
so you're out so the lease is the lease
is the lease is done correct
lease is done these payments are done i
would i would need until the end of this
year and that's when the lease is
technically up and that's why i need to
make a decision
am i buying this car am i going to turn
it in yeah should i buy and sell it yeah
if you don't
if you uh gary if i were you if i didn't
have the cash to go ahead and buy it
whatever that if that
if it's that 15 grand or less at the end
of the year depending on the lease
payments
i wouldn't buy it i would i would be
done with it
even though you kind of take the hit and
then just start over
chalk that up as a mistake and then go
pay cash for another car
because that's good okay how far cheaper
than 15 grand
what's your penalty gonna be do you know
uh well if i keep on driving it like the
that 25 cents a mile is just going to
start cueing accruing that's just going
to
be ridiculous i think at the end of the
year yeah so like that's why i'm trying
to like
kind of like what should i do with this
car like do you guys think like taking
out a loan
and then like trying to sell it and then
pay back the loan
immediately once i sell the car and then
do it
no it's kind of like not like yeah no
i wouldn't advise that because the only
time i would take out a loan is if you
were upside down in the car
not through a car lease but a car alone
you're trying to pay the gap off and get
out of
that yeah so i i would get out of the
lease as soon as possible gary if that's
at the end of the year do it and then
just scratch it up to stupid tax that's
what we call it around here
and so you would pay that off and then
go buy a car that's going to get you
yeah that's going to let you use this
car because you're going to run into the
ground anyways
you don't need a brand new one
hope that yep gary sorry that's an
expensive
whap upside the head huh yes
don't get a lease with a mileage cap if
you're in a
job that requires you to try to be a
traveling salesman
come on parents you got it gary you can
do it though
i believe in you because it's a good
clap this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
825-5225 taking your calls on money
and life let's go to justin in new york
city justin what's going on
hi guys uh nice to speak with you um
i've been listening to
dave for a long time and i've been
focusing on my family
my wife and myself and our income and
getting our debts taken care of and such
but it took me a while to realize that
my in-laws have
been failing on their own and i'm trying
to get them to
move out of their home and downsize to a
smaller house
and having that conversation hasn't been
going so well um
and you know my brother-in-law's been
giving them money to take care of
the mortgage for a while and they just
they can't afford the house they live in
they do have equity in it and i'm trying
to get them to sell
and cash out and then downsize i wanted
to get your opinion on
how to go about what's there reasoning
justin
to stay in the home that they can't
afford and they're having to take money
from their
son to pay their money i'm not i don't i
don't quite understand
all of it but it's it's you know they've
been the house for 25 years
okay they've come to live in that
lifestyle and
downsizing just i guess and they think
they'll be looked down upon i guess
it's a hurt to their ego it's like a
kind of a little bit of an evil it's
correct
not enough of an ego hit that they're
going to take money from their children
to cert
keep this mirage that's what i've been
saying yeah
so this is going to be hard to hear i
don't get it
yeah and that's here's the thing there's
nothing you can do man
um you can i say nothing you can you can
force the bottom
you can be a kind person you can have
this
one hard conversation where you are
respectful and you treat them with
dignity
and you you take a more
curious route hey tell me about what
what the plan is moving forward
you're working on your legacy with their
daughter and with whatever family you
are going to have
it can become a curiosity thing but man
you can't walk in and make anybody do
anything and as you know this isn't a
math problem when grown people start
taking money for their
from their kids not for food but for a
fantasy
man we have left the the
the cognitive reasoning area right
that that ship has sailed yeah
absolutely i mean that that's it justin
i mean it's kind of a
it's a it's a hard answer to your
question which is how do i convince my
in-laws that they need to downsize you
can't convince them i mean i think that
you can be a place to say
you you and your wife can choose not to
enable that behavior so if their son
can't afford it gets to a point where he
can't afford the house payment
you guys can set a very clear boundary
that we're not going to help you fund
this lifestyle and we're
we will not be that back up i mean
there's things you know that you
and your wife can have together to know
this is how we're going to do our life
in our marriage
um versus how they're doing it but yeah
there is no convincing unless they're
asking questions and want to know
so justin have you sat down with your
brother-in-law
and talked to him about his enabling of
of their lifestyle
yeah i've been having that conversation
as recently and uh
he gets it and he understands but i
don't know if he's
assertive enough to um you know
really go hard and cut them off to kind
of direct them in the direction
they need to go well i think for you
justin if there's
one more thing you can do just for your
own self
and tell me you're the therapist over
there but i mean for you
because you and your wife i'm sure are
concerned and you hate this for them
because it's eating up their money
they're having to take money for i mean
it's just not it's not a good situation
so for you too because it's it's her
parents it's not your parents
so both of you or even just her to say
hey mom and dad and it's the last
conversation we're gonna have about it
but for myself
i just need to say out loud i'm
concerned about you guys
i hate that this is where life has taken
you and i just
i see the writing on the wall and i feel
like you would have a better quality of
life if this house wasn't sucking the
life out of you and you're having you
can't afford it so as your daughter
that's what i see
whether you choose to take that or not i
just need to say that for myself
and then that's it like i don't know
yeah and at the end of the day
anything you carry with you justin and
it's gonna be hard for you to hear
is a choice to make your day worse is a
choice to make your marriage have
conflict in it because you can't do
anything about that conflict
like rachel said you and your wife can
talk about
how firm your boundaries are gonna be
not if but when they come knocking on
your door for money
how firm your boundaries are gonna be if
and when they lose this house because
they run out of money
and they're gonna have to move in with
you y'all can have those conversations
now
but man there's no sense in just beating
your head against the wall it's not
gonna change it's frustrating
and parents don't rob your kids of their
legacy
because you're living in a fantasy world
don't do that to your children
if it if you need money for food if you
need money for
medical care yeah you call your family
if you think wow
we got this really big house and it's
important to us because we feel don't do
that to your legacy
come on all right let's go to tj in
nampa tj what's going on
all right afternoon rachel thanks for
taking my call i appreciate it
you got it man thanks for calling in
what's up
well well i just want i need a little
bit further advice on uh what next to
target on our debt snowball here
got a genius sitting next to me so you
called the right place brother so what's
up
well um wife and i of course uh didn't
uh do the smart things we were actually
pretty dumb early on and
took out a bunch of student loans going
to college and after we both
graduated we're done with school uh here
we are we ended up with
uh combined between the two of us we got
uh just over 100k in uh student loan
debt
we rised up after we had
shocker when there was a kind of a
family event that happened and it forced
us to move back in with my folks
for about three years but during that
time we paid off all of our
unsecured debt other than
just the student loans and now we've
finally started to climb back towards
solvency and we we got the house that
we've
been in for about three years we just
recently refinanced it
to get it down to a fixed uh 20 year it
was on a 30-year variable
and we owe about 140 on it right now
payment on the house is just over 9 30
payment on the
student loans right now most of them are
ibr and the rest
some total about 220 but that's not even
enough to cover interest on the
on the loan
and so your question tj is which one to
pay off you're asking the student loan
or the house
right because we're to the point now our
vehicles are paid off
our credit cards are paid off we finally
got smart and
buckled down paid off about fourteen
thousand dollars in credit card
good for you guys thank you and then we
also paid off both
uh vehicles um but now we're just to the
point where we want to know what to
tackle next
um if we tackle the house it's not much
more as far as the the balance
but the the strain on the budget is much
greater i hear that yeah
it might help us to snowball the student
loans on the other hand the student
loans
the interest is killing us it's actually
the balances have gone up this year over
the last even with our payment
yep i hear you well i'm going to stick
to our rule of thumb
which is paying off all of your debt at
your house and so that student loan it's
the last one
and it's the hardest mathematically it's
the hardest mentally because it is a
mountain to climb right you like you
guys killed fourteen thousand dollars in
credit card debt like yeah
a hundred grand is a lot so is that
hundred grand
how many are there are there multiple
loans within that number i'm assuming
yeah there's about uh eight to ten okay
so what i would do tj because there's
almost a mental game to this we always
talk to people about when you're paying
off debt
that you need that momentum right and
you guys kind of felt that i could hear
in your voice yeah we paid off fourteen
thousand dollars in credit cards
like you couldn't feel it so on a sheet
of paper
i i would i would map out i would break
out that hundred grand so instead of
trying to tackle everest
you kind of have these little these
hills right that you're working towards
and that's going to continue guys on so
i i would
for sure tackle the student loan debt
and if you can break it up even just for
your own sanity
i feel like that that would be helpful
as well when we had my wife and i had
six figures of student loans we
this sounds so cheesy but we made little
little chains
yeah and they were of the little loans
right and
every time we got one every month we
would tear one off and some
months i would just sit there and we
actually hug it in our bedroom how's
that for that's real man
heavy uh bedroom decor sheila was like
thank you john thanks man
all i wanted no john you really just
know how to doll up a room but
it so much you sit there and see it and
it just
but you never forget it right and then
it gets smaller smaller
and yeah it's just biting that elephant
one eating that elephant one bite at a
time that's right
oh man thanks for that call tj just keep
plugging away
little steps little steps little steps
you got this you got this you got this
we'll be right back this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show i'm john
deloney joined here with best-selling
author rachel cruz taking your calls on
life
and money let's go to chilo in los
angeles california chilo what's up
hello how are you doing today
outstanding how are you
good good i had a question i have um my
daughter who's
about to turn 19 uh this month um she
has two thousand
two thousand dollars put away and she
actually had an investment i have no
idea
how to tell her how to invest it
um so i was wondering if i can get
guided or some advice on
how to help with that because i don't
want to steer in the wrong direction
what's her name her name
beautiful beautiful beautiful okay so
considering her age she's 19.
our advice usually for young people
around this age is
it's going to sound cheesy but it's just
true the best investment
is in themselves and so i think at a
young age
depending upon what's her education like
is she gonna go to
a four-year school is she going to
university or is she going to the
workforce
she's not sure yet what she wants to do
if she wants to go to school if she
wants to go to straight school she got
really um
um that's what i'm looking for she
basically got
when coveted hit it really rocked her
she was supposed to graduate she wasn't
able to walk her right yeah
yeah so she's kind of like in a funk so
to speak right now
yeah for sure um you know she's working
um
doing housekeeping um with her
uh mother's boyfriend and the two
thousand dollars that she has she
actually got it from uh that pandemic
money that california was offering and
so she hasn't touched it she said
i don't want to touch it i don't know
what to do with it but i know i want to
invest it
yeah so um right now you know schools
are really going to be opening back up
so she doesn't know if she's going to be
going to
college or trade school just work
full-time that's great
well well i'll tell you my advice would
be if she called me today
i would say two grand
at her age and with the her seasons of
life
changing so much right now that she
doesn't really have a firm plan
the best thing is just to keep it with
cash and a really boring
savings account or a money market
account right now um
because number one she may need that
money if she chooses to go to school to
help her with tuition
she may need that money if she wants to
go into the workforce and get an
apartment
and start i mean two grand in the grand
scheme of things right can can be a
pretty good boost for that 19 year old
so because when i
when i think about investing investing
for me is long
term which means five years or more
and while it's great mathematically to
start as young as possible again
having that cash available during all
these random transitions that she's
going to be occurring in the next
probably five years of her life
having some cash to spare is a real is a
huge blessing i mean that's huge so
i would relay to her hey i wouldn't put
it in the market right now
even though what you're thinking about
is so good like the fact she's even
thinking about investing at 19
props to her you have a very smart
daughter i was not but i
yeah so yeah she's way different than
dad for sure that's great
and i think that's awesome and i would
and encourage that in her
like that she's so smart that's so good
but i would have it
available for me at 19 to use during
this transition period and then once
she's out of school or if she goes to
trade school or she goes right into the
workforce and she has a little bit of a
steady
um steady stream of a season of life
that she sees and she says okay
now i'm gonna work to see if i can use
this if she has any debt to pay it off
or to keep it for a fully funded
emergency fund and then look into
retirement so
even though it's great to start early
mathematically speaking it's much better
to have cash available
at 19. i can't even tell you i think i
would smile for a month if my 19 year
old was like hey dad i got 2 000 bucks
that would make me smile
and on top of that would be i'm thinking
for the future dad
it's just it's awesome i married well
because that didn't come from me
all right daniel in orlando what's up
hey i just have a couple of i guess a
multi-part
question all right go for it what's up
we we're
in are just coming out of baby step two
uh where credit cards are paid off cars
we're right at the should have those
paid off at the end of this month
congratulations brother and then the
only thing appreciate it the only thing
left is our mortgage that's
first part second part is we own our
own business um and we do have a
business loan
and we use credit cards at the business
i mean i know
even though we pay them off we we're
looking at dropping those and just going
like dave says going with the debit
cards
um but i i'm trying to figure out how to
move forward
if we stuck to what we're doing now we
could probably have our home paid off by
the end of this year
but i don't know if i should just go
into
the 15 or do them all simultaneous
i guess as far as retirement goes how
much
is your business loan
probably close to about 80 000. 80 000.
how much how much you have left on your
mortgage
about a 137. okay
well technically with business debt i
mean it is still
your debt right your name's on it you're
responsible for it and that's the
conversation me and my wife are happy
totally so i yeah that's right
so i would go ahead and pay off the
business loan
um okay because you said you'll be able
to pay off your mortgage this year which
means you're going to have 80 grand this
year to pay off that business loan
so i would go ahead and relieve myself
of that
and then start looking at retirement
like you said you're 15
um past that and then just kind of chip
away at the house
um but that's that's the order i would
do because the hard thing with business
debt again i feel like people
function with two sides of their brain
almost they can like split it down the
middle and say well that's my business
side and this is my personal
but it's still you like you're you still
owe the money yeah you still have it so
that that's a conversation my wife yeah
it's a great and it's a great
conversation
it's personal i mean it i mean it's
still guaranteed by me
right exactly exactly so that's right
yeah we're still guaranteeing yet which
which kind of stinks in a way because at
least if you're paying off your house
it's like
you've a paid for asset for you
personally it feels so personal
where the business again feels like this
other part of your life but it is your
life so
i'd go ahead and pay off the business
loan if i were you daniel and with that
kind of that kind of income
you're you're almost you're flipping it
right so two years from now you're gonna
have a paid off house
yeah you're gonna have a debt-free
business right and then you can start
building up the business emergency fund
your homework fund that's fantastic
that's right that's right
have you ever made a dumb decision with
zeros on the end because you didn't do
your research
me too rachel probably has it i have
most people make choices based on
feelings or opinions
especially when they're buying a house
people fall in love with the house as
though it's a person right
but when it comes to the real estate
market feelings are not your friend
facts are so check your facts find out
what you can actually afford
research trending in home research
what's trending in home prices
talk to a reputable real estate person
in
your area never buy a house without the
facts again text
house to 33789 and get an agent who will
help you make smart decisions
that's house to three three seven
eight nine listen rachel i used a
ramsey real estate elp
it was incredible and here's why i come
from texas where you know
they ask for 150 000 for a house and you
say
i'll give you 110 and they're like pew
pew pew how about 140 right and we all
shake hands in the middle
in nashville that same house is 11
million dollars
and they expect you to give a million
dollars over the asking
yeah 12 million actually and write me a
letter and i want you to sing a song on
our front porch
and um we go ahead and invest in my
child's retirement account i mean it's
like bananas
so i had the first few houses we put
offers on
come now i feel like an idiot and
my real estate agent i'm a little bit
loud
and demonstrative and i'm like
john my elp she called and said we need
to have a talk about
um your expectations and about reality
and rachel her name's amanda she is
incredible she let me have it in the
most professional awesome way
totally recalibrated my brain kept my
marriage intact i think
and we ended up in an awesome house that
took too long to buy because the
national market's bananas but
having that person who was trained and a
person of integrity and who knew the
market sideways and forwards and would
say
this is a bad offer we're not doing this
right and would say hey this is a really
good deal this is what you're looking
for let's go for it yeah yep
so good that's the thing about i feel
like when it comes to our life these
parts of our lives that can be
complicated
and kind of intimidating if there's
people that work in them day in and day
out use it
like like let them do it have a
professional in your back pocket at all
times
it's awesome hey another hour in the
books thank you so much rachel
thank you james and kelly and bobby
bobertson
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show where america hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life
and your money i'm john delony joined
here with my good friend and
best-selling author
rachel cruz and we are taking calls
about your relationships and your money
and your mental health and everything
going on in your life give us a shout
triple 825-5225
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
let's jump to the phones let's talk to
jennifer in tampa florida jennifer
what's going on
hi thank you so much for taking my call
how are you guys we are outstanding
thank you
so much for giving us a shout so what's
up
so here's the back story my husband and
i make 140 000
we are saving for retirement second baby
on the way have a college fund for our
first child
we have about twenty thousand dollars in
the bank
we have fifteen thousand dollar
emergency fund baby
step six um we have seventy five
thousand dollars in a single stock
and our question is we're wondering if
we should invest
in the stock market or if we should pay
off our house
we have 200 000 left on our mortgage
the only issue is we know that we're
probably going to want to move within
the next five to 10 years
um not guaranteed but we know that we
would like to move
this isn't we don't believe in a forever
house but we don't think this is
our long-term house gotcha well y'all
are crushing it congratulations
we are we're very black we've been
listening dave ramsey for a while
that's so great so you're wondering if
you need to pay off the house
yeah should we pay off the house should
we
save um cash for our next house
um what is the single stock we want we
don't have to move
i'm sorry what's the single stock that
the 75 000
is sitting in is it work related stock
is it is it stock available from your
company or is it you just guys wouldn't
bought
a bunch of a stock it was um it was it
was the company my husband used to work
for
okay not investing okay
and what other retirement do you guys
have jennifer
um we're doing 15 percent you are
currently doing 15. we have four
yep we have 401k okay so you're doing
that okay so
what amount of money are you wondering
about are you worried about the 75 000
that's in the
that's in the uh single stock or the 20
grand that's in the savings account just
sitting there that's not the emergency
funds
all of that so i mean you got about yeah
about 100 grand yeah we're wondering
should we take
out the stocks um and it's been about 10
years
um since we've had that
and we have our emergency fund we have
twenty thousand dollars in the bank we
also
transferred another twenty thousand
dollars that's in
a separate account that we're putting
that towards the house every month
wow so should we just throw that all on
the mortgage so i guess we have forty
thousand dollars in the emergency
emergency fund yeah that's great good
for you guys yeah well obviously
yeah yeah so from the emergency fund oh
separate yes
well obviously keep that emergency fund
the 15 grand that you said i'm assuming
that's
your three to six months of expenses
leaving that cash in the bank
and then everything else combined that
that forty thousand dollars in savings i
would
yeah that that single stock i wouldn't
keep in especially since the company
doesn't work for anymore and it's
sort of a different story if you want to
buy into the company you're in all of
that but
you guys are out of that so i would take
that out and
i mean you could you could hit that
house real hard jennifer i mean you
could you could pay off half the
mortgage
with just that cash um and how old are
you guys
we're 32. 32. yeah so you have you have
time for retirement and you guys are
still funding 15
which is awesome i would i would
continue that 15
out of your 140 income and then i would
take some of this and just throw it at
the house jennifer because if you guys
how young you are i mean if you guys get
to 36 with a paid for home
retirement just going i mean you're in a
real good spot
and i would yeah i would i guess go
ahead i guess our only problem is
that we think that we'll we don't know
but we think we might move within the
next five to ten years oh that's right
you said that pay off the house
that's kind of our concern so here's if
i go back five years
that's three jobs in two states ago for
me that i didn't see coming
if i go back 10 years it's actually for
us too that's even more right so
it's good to have this dream on the
whole like depending on the ups and
downs of the real estate market you're
not gonna this money's not just gonna
evaporate on you
on the opposite side you're gonna have
no house payment two young kids you're
going to be able to be a lot more
flexible with
whatever comes your way so i'm with
rachel man i would pay this house off
asap
and you were way down the road on that i
would definitely sell that single stock
yeah and even
even though you guys might be moving you
have a paid for house i mean all that
equity it's not like
that money's going on the drain i mean
that's you've paid for a house so when
you when you sell
you get all the money you get all that i
mean you get that money it's there yeah
so so yep that's what we're gonna do
thanks jennifer you are crushing off
that's so good man all right let's go to
ashley in jacksonville ashley how's it
going
going good how are you good good good
how can we help
yeah so i graduated with my bachelor's
degree
with zero debt and i'm
currently planning to start grad school
in the fall
in january i'm actually looking at
either
english or humanities i'm looking at a
career in academia so i'm trying to
figure out where exactly i want to
position myself
gotcha so
in january i bought a car and
put half down financed the rest that's
my first and only
debt so i currently have thirty thousand
dollars
in savings to cash flow
grad school awesome and i'm wondering
right now is it
a smart idea to go ahead and just
completely kill the car loan and
pay that off before i start grad school
or
or should i kind of put that through how
much do you have left on the car
uh about ten thousand ten grand okay
um yeah i would go ahead and tackle the
car
um because grad school you're gonna have
obviously it's it's
very expensive but you have time chunks
of time right to
to pay it as you go um
where if you get this car out of the way
that debt all your income can go
towards aka investing in yourself
actually i mean putting that money
towards grad school to continue afloat
um which i believe you can do because
like you went through undergrad
which you're crazy weird right now yeah
you you're without them
how did you do that ashley people are
wondering that because everyone
graduates
with student loans everyone does that's
normal how'd you do it
yeah yeah so i had really great
supportive
parents so i lived with them
for the first bunch of school i actually
went to
the community college i got two
associate degrees
through there and worked through school
um so i was paying as i went
um i also was able to get a pretty good
gpa
so i got a scholarship to go to
university
and i actually was able to finish up
university in only three semesters
because i had done so much
uh through the community college and
your degree is from the university that
you wanted and you paid
very fraction of it because of what you
did ashley you're so smart
so smart well done yeah well done pay
that car off and
before my mom is an english professor
those jobs
are hard to come by these days so before
you go to grad school
sit down with a person who works in that
field
and get some real life
information about what that lifestyle is
like what the what the money on that
life is going to be and what the day to
day is going to be it's usually
different than people think it's the roi
it's a hard life beautiful we need good
english professors but it's tough
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show i'm john
deloney joined here with rachel cruz
ramsey personality
taking your calls on life and money
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window covering you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best
deal rules and restrictions apply
rachel today's question comes from
herbert new york
i'm a history professor at an expensive
private university
students from my department will most
likely not go on to make a six figure
income
as most of them want to teach part of my
job is to recruit students into my
my departments but i cannot in good
conscience tell them
to take out loans i know most of them do
because they couldn't afford
private tuition otherwise what do i say
to students to get them to my department
but at the same time being realistic
realistic
that my major is maybe not the best
thing for their financial future
that's a hard one john what do you think
oh
man well that's hard
this particular person um
yeah the values of their institution the
values of the place that that pays for
their paycheck
is not in line with the values that sit
on his pillow every night
and one of the questions i would have if
herb was just hanging out here and we
have a cup of coffee and he's asking me
the same question
it would go deeper than that for me
because he's doing a good job of
distancing himself from this issue and
making it a moral and ethical issue for
them not for him
the reality is his business
is supported by something he didn't
believe in
so it's not so much as it's it you can
flip this around right he doesn't want
students to go into debt
and he's having a hard time encouraging
them to take on debt to get a degree
that he knows they're going to struggle
to pay back
yep but deeper than that where i want to
charge challenge herb is
you're taking a salary from a company
that doesn't align with your values and
he's got a hard question
he's taking care of these students but
he's not really getting to the root of
the question
yeah which is do i believe in where i
even work
and we we've taken calls on this show
like hey i
wanted to work in finance my whole life
my whole life and i got my first job out
of college at a local bank
and all i'm doing is selling loans right
and i spent all this time getting out of
debt and i don't think i can keep doing
this
right yeah and so i think everybody
everybody has to have that hard
conversation
does what put food on my table align
with my values
yep and you don't always have to go
running for the hills right
like i gotta quit today and i'm gonna
sure sure sure
but i do think that's a worthy
conversation to have herb i'm gonna tell
you
i know a number of people i've had this
exact conversation with a number of my
friends across the united states
some of them have said i've got to get
out of work in higher ed i can't keep
doing this
some have made a transition from this
from a private
you know expensive private school to a
community college
some of them have just said man this is
what it is what it is right
the students are grown-ups they can
choose to make this decision on their
own and we're going to keep blown ahead
the value proposition is different from
everybody but man herb you're not going
to be able to sleep
i'm telling you right now based on that
question yep what do you recommend to
folks who are balancing yeah
i don't i don't believe in where i work
anymore
because it's a complete it's a complete
mind shift right
yeah from what you saw was okay and
normal
to suddenly realizing in probably his
own life oh wow i don't i hate debt i'm
going to get out well
and now i'm here assuring a new
generation a generation right into it
knowing that they're going to get jobs
that aren't going to even support
them financially to pay off the debt
like well and if you're any kind of
professor
who obviously herb's good at what he
does just because of his this
the the depth of this question you talk
to students all day long
and you hear what's on their heart mind
and what's number one on their heart
mind is
i'm never gonna be able to pay this back
ever i'm never gonna be able to pay this
back so this is probably a bigger
question that you can answer but you
worked kind of in the sector in life
like you've
for a long time yeah you've been a part
of it so how do we
and again it's a bigger conversation but
prop the next generation and say yes
education is good and we need people in
all these fields right like the last
call we just took was about an english
professor
uh his wasn't it yeah about one to be an
english professor yeah yes and all of
that in the roi and
yes uh going to school and grad school
and all that and you mentioned yeah just
make sure you talk to someone that's
been in that world so you know
so like how do we keep all of that
because we need that in our society like
we need
english professors we need people that
are getting degrees in
fields that are not supported
financially do you know what i'm saying
but the degree is so expensive like it's
just
it feels like a not a lost cause but
it's defeating
it's it's sitting in rc because i'm like
man you believe in all that stuff and
you and you love the people in those
institutions and they're great but it
just feels like it's broken
yeah i think that's what it comes down
to is i am
i am somebody who believes deeply
that we have let go
the arts we have let go english we have
let go the ability to read and discern
some of these problems we're having
now writers have been writing on the
stuff for hundreds if not thousands of
years
right but we don't teach history anymore
we don't teach them these things anymore
because it's all about roi what's the
roi on this job we get a coding job
so i think we lose something i really
really do yeah
and you can't charge 150 000 dollars
first
for a job it's it's a better they're
gonna make forty thousand dollars
i think it's both and i think everybody
in this conversation
has to put it on the table sure and i
will say i i know
a number of higher ed leaders that are
trying to fix it from inside out i know
a number of tech companies that are
trying to solve it from the outside
and we all got a great lesson this last
year man just throwing everything online
and gonna solve it either
that has been miserable and we also
learned a lot how can you make online
learning better because it
could be cheaper but you're right it's a
mess yeah right and we need some
grown-ups to stop acting like kids
and actually say we're gonna be a part
of some of these solutions and there's
some
really bold higher ed leaders who are
making some major changes there are some
bold
tech folks who are weighing in so i
think we're going to see some
significant shifts
and i hope hope hope for the sake of our
kids it's not at the expense of reading
in history and music but it's at the
expense of
man it's not a four-year vacation
anymore yeah right that's right
that was a moment that's what's wild is
that the four-year
institution college as what we knew when
we went
probably like it is what it is it was
affordable you could you know i mean all
of it i mean and not that you can't
still go to school
debt free we just got a call from
someone that did it you can figure it
out you can do it yeah
but it's uh it has shifted and bring in
2020 when
most of the universities were closed and
it was online yeah it's just i mean it's
it's a shifting we don't have a solution
if eight if however many millions of
eighteen-year-olds just hit the job
market tomorrow in 1982
we can't absorb that either right so
it's not as simple as close all the col
that's a bad decision
sure sure and so yeah it's gonna take
some leadership
which is the key here and some people
being really honest about what
tomorrow's gonna look like and some
people not getting what they want et
cetera et cetera
and that brings us back to her you're
gonna have to have a hard conversation
with the mirror my brother
and not only about these students you're
gonna have to
have a hard conversation about where it
does your income
come from do you align with the values
of where you
where you draw a paycheck from and can
you do what your job asks you to do and
if your job is asking you
to do something that violates your core
value system you got to find the job man
yeah you got to
and that's not higher just higher
education that is that's absolutely
every
job you're listening yep that's it or
you work at a gas station and you get a
new manager that asks you to do stuff
right it's like it's everywhere you got
to have those core set of values and say
this is where my line is yes right
yes which is part of knowing yourself
and that's a lot of the stuff you talk
about
you got to know yourself is the
self-awareness of that i mean like it's
it's huge understanding why you do the
things you do that's right
and and and where you co yeah you talk
about it too i think
all of us distilled down to this idea of
you got to be intentional you got to be
intentional that's right
all right russ let's uh russell let's go
to russell i'm just going to say russell
about eight times here russell in
virginia beach what's up russell how are
we doing
hey how are y'all today i appreciate you
taking my call oh hey brother listen
i messed up the clock here hang on here
and we're gonna roll you over and we'll
get you right after this break
i should have just kept talking for a
second i tried to i tried to extend this
a little bit john
i'm not going to lie well i talk about
self-awareness
should we talk about self-awareness
we'll get there
we'll come to you soon we'll be right
back russell this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
825-5225 we're taking your calls on life
and money i'm john delonie joined by
rachel cruz we're going back to
russell in virginia beach russell what's
going on brother
russell are you there my man yeah i'm
here
one of the key things about uh answering
the phone is actually picking it up so
sorry about that so what's up man we're
definitely here hey i'm seeking some
advice today
go for them i'm quickly approaching
about 35 years of service in the navy
oh thank you congratulations man yeah
thanks i appreciate that it's been an
awesome experience so uh recently bought
a home when we transferred back to
virginia
um the home was about a half million
bucks
and uh my wife and i have no credit card
or car loans the home is really it and
so
we've done pretty well we've got about
400 in mutual funds
uh which we continue to invest in we've
got another
roughly 230 between roth ira and off psp
and continue to contribute to that we've
got about 115
in cash so my question is
is it a smart move knowing that i'm
going into retirement at least from the
military
and to take a large chunk of money say
300 000
out of my mutual funds to put on the
house
which would allow me to pay the house
off by like 20 29.
if you pulled out the three how much do
you owe on the house total today
4.90 4.90 okay now all the mutual funds
you just rattled off a lot of them were
roth so are they all
retirement specific mutual funds no no
no the
the 400 of it is just mutual funds oh
it's just a mutual fund okay so no
penalties if you cash that out
there's no retirement penalties there no
yes just tax right yep yep
um yeah i mean russell if i were you
if you if you wanted to take a chunk and
throw it at the house
because your other retirement i mean you
have some other retirement the ones you
you just named my yeah my first year out
of service
uh my retirement will be eighty thousand
take them
okay yes
i i would if i were you um again i would
not take out for those listening i would
not cash out retirement in order to pay
off that yeah no i wasn't planning on
catching that
yeah exactly but the mutual fund i mean
you have 400 in it
yeah you could take a chunk of it and
throw it at the house because a goal
um obviously is to pay off the home
and to be able to you'll be getting that
80 grand
from your service and you'll you have
these other these other vehicles
for retirement which you can live off of
as well so having a paid for close to
paid for
paid for home in that big time is is
huge
so russell i'm i'm uh curious
30 years in the service
and now you think yeah you're
transitioning out to become a civilian
what are you gonna do
that's the million-dollar question i
have some ideas
i have a side hustle i breed snakes uh
so that's well
that's what my little brother does my
brother does that too
yep i've been doing it for about 20
years okay what kind of snakes
does it make a lot of money but it
brings in about 20 a year
yeah wow that's a pretty good gig
do you use real live mice or frozen ones
there you go that's a true breeder right
there we could really get off the rails
on this conversation russell
i like you we could we could but yeah so
go ahead go ahead i was gonna say i i
i'm
a hundred percent with rachel i love the
idea of
you having that great military pension
which you've earned every penny of
and having a paid for house or really
close to paid for house
and um man getting this jet set off
whatever the rest of your life's gonna
be
having the greatest reptile sale
online salesman in the country man
russell the snake man i love it
all right let's go to maggie in san
diego maggie what's going on
uh hi thank you for taking my call um
i'm new to the program
so i'm just starting off in the baby
steps i'm on number two to our band of
weirdos maggie we're glad that you're
here
thank you thank you um so i moved in
with my aunt to be her full-time
caregiver
um and three years ago she put my name
on her unless we did a grant bead
but now i'm debating if i should sell my
house
since those prices are skyrocketing
right now in order to pay off her house
as well as
pay off the rest of my debt because if i
keep the house that
my house i could use it as an investment
you know later on down the line and have
that as a secure
monthly income but if i sell it off now
that's like a quick
way to kind of get ahead sure
maggie how much debt do you have that
you want to pay off
um the only that i have is my car
payments for my kids and that's about
28 000. 28 000 car payments for your
kids why aren't they paying their own
car payment
uh well i i did make some prompts to my
kids before they went off to college
that i'd buy them a car so they wouldn't
have to worry about transportation
so uh you know i'm still making the
payments on them
all right that's another phone call
that's another phone call
um maggie so you have those car payments
28 grand
and that's it except for your aunt's
home that you are on now on the deed
of and how much is the home
her house is there's probably about a
hundred
and thirty thousand left on her house on
my house um that i'm not even living in
right now my husband is there pretty
much by himself
um is about two hundred and eighty
thousand left that we owe
that two 280 and how much how much is it
worth how much
equity would you get from it it's worth
about 600 000.
oh wow okay and how much is your aunt's
house worth
probably about 550 something like that
500 okay
and so your husband is in your home yeah
so does he want to move in with your
aunt
is he is he on board with this well he
doesn't want to but he's going to help
you
well played well played that sounds like
i should probably have a breakfast
together and talk about this
uh what what is that what's the plan
here for
are are you is your is your aunt
terminal are you planning on
taking over the home after she can have
to move to a
care at some point to skilled nursing or
something
we're going to take care of her here
because i'm already i am a nurse so
she'll get the best care for me so is
there any other
family drama that doesn't like this that
are
sitting you mean notes about it or is
everybody happy that hey you take the
house you take
ant and we're going to move on yes sir
everyone's okay with i mean they know
i'm the closest one too that's why she
couldn't
she did a grant b when her husband died
so we wouldn't have a problem with it
okay it's been i i i don't i
my my hesitation maggie is you putting
your money on a home
that you're that the deed is split so
it's not your entire home it is
her home so that feels a little messy to
me i would rather it be
her home or your home that you take over
and you say i'm gonna just
that you're you know aunt you're sick
you don't need the burden of this
i'm gonna just buy it from you and
there'd be a clean
line there so that's one conversation i
would probably have maggie this feels a
little bit
convoluted when with both of you on the
deed i don't really care for that
um but also yeah if you're not living in
the house and you guys are going to be
living with your aunt for the
foreseeable future you don't need your
other home
um but you also but also the car
payments are 28 000
which is a lot but you could work and
pay that off keep the home
rent it out do something with it because
it has great equity so it's basically do
you want to mess with the home do you
not
because if you had if you had 150
000 in student loan debt this probably
would be a different conversation
but the 28 000 you probably could put
the pedal to the metal and get it paid
off quick and still have your home if
you wanted to keep it
or you could say i don't even it's not
even worth the trouble messing with
renters any of that we're gonna just
cash out get the equity out uh pay off
that and have a big chunk of change in
the bank
which which feels good to me as well
what's the status of your marriage
well that's a whole other conversation
sir that okay
um we we're like i said i just started
with the baby because we've been coming
for 21 years we've never mixed our
finances ever
[Music]
but that's something that we that i do
want to certainly now
yeah you know i just felt like it was a
waste to
you know have that second house i
totally get that
it's not uncommon that couples who have
been in your situation they've been
had parallel lives they've been married
for a long time they've had a great
relationship but they haven't been fully
together
then one of them goes to be a primary
caregiver for somebody else and the
whole thing
comes unglued so i want you to go get
with your husband and y'all have some
hard conversations about
what the next 20 years are going to look
like you got a guy's got to do this
together
otherwise you're going to end up um all
by yourself and i don't want that for
either
okay we thinking about your marriage
hang in there maggie this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
daniel 10 14
and came to make you understand what it
is to happen to your people
in the latter days for the vision is
four days yet to come
never give up on a dream just because of
the time it will take to accomplish it
the time will pass away earl nightingale
well that's kind of deep hold on let's
hear that again never give up on a dream
just because of the time it will take to
accomplish it
the time will pass anyway yeah so
it's going to pass anyway you might as
well put it toward a dream a fun
there's a couple that my wife knows back
in texas and
they were talking about they were like
35 and they were
chit-chatting with one another and they
were both like man we both wanted to go
to med school
and be doctors and they went and talked
to somebody and the person said
well here's the deal you're gonna be 42
anyway
the question you are asking is do we go
to med school or not it's
when you're 42 do you want to be doctors
or not yeah and it's going to happen
that way so
why not right what is the obsession with
this so i love that quote man figure it
out
both my parents have made major shifts
later in life and it's just
adds a whole new universe i think that's
a fun story when i hear people
that yeah they get to their 50s or 60s
like you know what i'm gonna and they
just whatever it is yeah and you're like
man they just started this whole new
life still haven't
lost it's almost how you see it right
but it's not the end no
you're just i just wanna i just wanna
slide in the end with no tread left on
the tire
yeah that's right that's right all right
let's go to bethany in scranton
pennsylvania home of the office how are
we doing bethany
i'm good how are you good are you an
office fan or do you get beat up with
that all the time
hey my husband turned me into an office
band
well you married well
thank you you married well so what's up
how can we help thank you
um i have a quick question i'm a
stay-at-home mom
and my husband and i have been on
babysit
baby steps excuse me four ish
um for a while we're just not quite at
the 15
and i was just wondering if you would
ever recommend um
lowering that 15 just so that we can
have some movement
in baby steps five and six how old are
you guys bethany
i am 33 we're both 33 okay
and how much do you guys make my
husband makes a little under 50 000 a
year
okay and you're a stay at home mom you
said
um yes so the
the mathematical reason for the 15 is
that it will guarantee that you will get
to retirements
with dignity that you won't have the
money to be able to live your dreams
and all of that um and so that 15
we we stick pretty hard on just to
ensure that that's going to happen
um but you guys for the income and for
your house specifically um because your
kid's college you're not a bad parent if
you don't pay for your kids college like
we've talked on here that you can
you can send them to school they can do
community college for for a few years
transfer to a state school like
they can have a great and honestly by
the time your kids are in college as
we've been talking who knows what that
world is going to look like
so if you don't have the cash to be able
to invest right now in your kids college
you're not a bad parent
but looking ahead at the house uh how
much do you guys owe on the house
um i think around 86 186 okay
yeah so i would if i were you bethany i
would stick with that 15
for a little for a little bit longer and
then just i would i would almost
um start because of your income and
everything
start chipping away a little bit at the
house if you have any to throw
towards an esa or something it would be
very helpful for your kids i mean that's
in the order of the baby steps for sure
um but it's just gonna be a little bit
at a time like it may not just be this
this huge you know you it's not this
huge shovel that you have that you're
throwing all this money at and all that
right i mean like you guys are having to
be very very diligent to do it all
that is what i that was my question
rachel uh bethany what's your husband do
my husband's a pastor he's a pastor
there awesome
is there a potential for him to pick up
some
additional income on the side for a few
years to
knock that house out um
he could if if someone is going to be
driven in our house to do it it would
probably be naped
okay so we're just not that he's not
driven
but he's carrying a lot of hats um just
he's the only pastor on staff
um and which means he's the pastor and
plumber
and yard guy and hospital chaplain
what's y'alls um
take home pay at bethany a month how
much
y'all make a month a month just shy of 4
000 i think and how much is that
mortgage payment
all right so around 650 650 okay
yeah that's not not terrible at all
yeah that percentage yeah yeah
absolutely
man y'all are really trying to do it
you're doing it um
there's been seasons of my life when
they've been just that which are seasons
right which are we can continue to you
know
somebody stay home we're gonna keep in
this job and we can do it for this
season
for the next two years or three years or
five years and then there becomes the
math problem right
we either have to get to a point where
we can pay this off or
we have to get to a point where we can
reach that retirement goal right
otherwise yeah you're going to continue
you're going to find yourself 43
and 53 you mean a very similar boat
right and you're not going to be any
further towards any of these goals at
all right
and that's a hard place to be good for
you and your family though for
having your values and knowing who you
are and what you want to be about and
then you're going to make it happen
absolutely it's it's a little bit of
that contentment issue too bethany you
know because
unless something changes with his salary
as a pastor or something drastic i mean
um yeah the numbers are and and i think
you know god's called you to this place
if that's what you
you know you guys are in it for a reason
um
i believe in that discernment in your
life and your husband's life that you
guys have chosen this
because you know you're called to it and
so it is it's just gonna there's gonna
be a level of contentment
um that you're probably gonna have to
find as as a
as a stay-at-home mom too um i can just
speak as a wife right like i mean
you're you're on instagram and facebook
and see it all and so there's just a
level of saying hey god has us here for
a reason and it's not gonna be big and
flashy
we're not gonna pay off the house in two
years i mean that's not gonna be the
story but that's okay
but that's okay but you guys are staying
diligent being smart
with the money that you do have and so
you guys are doing great
as somebody who um we've had this in our
home
you've had to make decisions like am i
going to take this speaking gig for this
much money
oh sure i'm going to stay at home oh 100
yeah and there's a real true cost
to yep my values are here right
whatever they may be right and it's
getting to that
how do you help somebody get to that
contentment because i struggle with that
it's hard i made this choice but living
with
what that choice means it can be hard
yes very much so i mean i
i feel like gratitude is one of the
first places to start
and i know it's kind of like the cheesy
answer but it's true but it's
uh christine kane i love what she says
she says that
gratitude is not thankful for what he's
given us
it's to be thankful for what he's
entrusted to us so everyone's life looks
different of what's
what i believe in a spiritual sense
right god has entrusted to you
and what you have and so being grateful
for that
um i think a level of it is humility and
giving and serving and knowing that the
world's not all about you yeah
and that you looking up to say okay what
what can i do to serve and help people
in bethany gill's entire life is that
your one of service and it's
and it's an amazing calling um and so
there's a lot of that and then i think
there's like a level of maturity too
yeah emotional and spiritual maturity
right to be able to kind of say
okay we're here it's not always fun i'm
choosing to stay at home
i really want to go out to eat tonight
right but we made this choice that's
right and not beating yourself up when
you have those secondary thoughts right
those why can't we just go to florida
like everybody else
because we chose this and you can have
both and yes
yes that's right and it's hard i
remember talking i had two sets of
friends
and two were lawyers here in nashville
and just
working insane hours i mean like kids
were in daycare
she had mom guilt it was terrible but
they are doing it because they said at
the end of it
or like we'll get to a point where we
don't have to work these hours but we're
going to make a big income so that we
can enjoy
take our kids on vacation we want them
to have experiences whatever it is so
they valued that
right or wrong people probably have
opinions but that is what they chose
where i had another friend four kids
he's a teacher yeah history teacher and
coach she's she stays at home yep so
talk about a tight budget they just
figured out
and they said yeah we know we can't do
all these things but this is what we're
choosing and that's the beautiful thing
about all of this there's
a level of choice right that we have of
what you value when you live out of
those values
that's where the joy and contentment can
come back to contentment right chasing
it someone else's
that doesn't work for you well that's
another show on the books i want to
thank
james childs and kelly daniel for their
incredible engineering work
and call screening action thanks to my
good friend rachel cruz
this has been the ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit daveramsey.com
show and register we would love for you
to come to nashville and tell your story
you